the world is dying we are no longer at
the top of the food chain cities have
fallen to ruin as friends and neighbors
transform into mindless Predators
faceless monsters guard the ruins
denying us the derelict remains of our
past dignity humans are going extinct
and all of it all of it is because of
this
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the fun guy who's here to talk about
fungi ladies and gentlemen it's that
time again time for the transmedia
landscape to result in us talking about
video games here on the film and TV
channel that's because the last of us
just like Sonic League of Legends and
Pokemon before it is the latest in the
line of games that's been turned into a
fantastic movie or TV show take that
game theory that's another piece from
your toy box that's ours now
wait am I am I laughing at myself with
this joke I'm in charge of all of these
channels what's going on in case you're
not Elite gamer like all of us over here
let me catch you up The Last of Us
started its life in 2013 as a video game
that set a new Benchmark for cinematic
storytelling in the medium this story of
a wounded man and his surrogate daughter
trying to survive a world devastated by
a zombie apocalypse immediately cemented
itself as a pivotal piece of gaming
history the moment that gaming stood up
and shouted yes we too can have
emotional movie quality stories now to
be completely honest gaming had already
had plenty of other Amazing Stories in
the past but this was the moment when
the visuals and the story both reached a
point where no one could deny Gaming's
artistic properties anymore the game was
so good that Sony just had to release it
on the PS3 and the PS4 and the PS5 again
all in under 10 years no less and here
we thought rebooting movies happened
quickly anyway now here in 2023 the
dramatic Prestige video game has been
turned into a dramatic Prestige
streaming Series in fact as both top
tier Gamers and top tier movie nerds
Steph and I were lucky enough to get
invited to the premiere on that note
this video is hashtag not spawn but
considering the amount of free popcorn
that I ate that night might as well have
been
number two I am making them hey
Premiere that we're at hey you invite me
to a place where I'm getting free
unlimited popcorn and Diet Coke I am
gonna make you hurt so after meeting
some of the team who worked on the show
who also happen to be fans of food
theory that was a fun little twist and
then stealth on our way down the red
carpet Stephanie walk in the black
carpet the private black carpet that we
still fully avoid it they're like are
you sure you don't want to walk the red
carpet like no thanks because I
literally break down the barrier it was
time for the show the first of the
episodes the last stuff awesome honest
review it's great I get nervous whenever
anyone tries to adapt such a perfectly
told story but I gotta admit they nailed
it sure they made some changes to the
source material which we're gonna talk
about here in a second but it never
detracted from the core story so with
yet another series showing that the
video game bad movie Curse is not a real
thing anymore we finished by dancing the
night away you heard of the fungi attack
but now the fun guy attack though to be
fair we didn't party as hard to sum
now as you might have guessed at this
point the zombies and The Last of Us
function a bit differently from your
usual apocalyptic scenario in most media
you're dealing with a blood-borne virus
that's spread through bites but not so
much here what makes the last of us so
interesting is that it's all a fungus in
fact the show spends its entire opening
scene laying out why a fungal pandemic
would be terrifying using real science
to lay out exactly what would happen
there's a fungus that infects insects
gets inside an ant for example fungus
starts to direct the ants Behavior
telling it where to go what to do so it
begins to devour its host from within
replacing the ants flesh with its own
the fungus the scientist is talking
about is a real thing called cordyceps
which we've actually talked about
multiple times over on the sister
location Game Theory it is terrifying
stuff but something that we shouldn't
have to worry about right I mean the
show claims that fungal infections of
this type cannot survive if its hosts
internal temperature is over 94 degrees
but then they ask what if that changes
what if for instance the world was to
get slightly warmer man HBO sure loves
using Zombie Invasions as a metaphor for
climate change huh
if only Westeros had reduced its
greenhouse gas emissions what's crazy
though is how quickly Things Fall Apart
in the world of The Last of Us seriously
it basically felt like over the course
of just a day or two everyone everywhere
all at once suddenly had their brains
hijacked by a fungus like it was a
five-star Grand Theft Auto Rampage
suddenly zombie Runners are in houses in
the streets planes crashing out of the
sky what happened and it's here that we
actually get to one of the big
differences between the game and the new
series as well as our main theory for
today how did the fungus spread so
quickly in the new HBO series The Last
of Us you see in the game part of the
reason the cordyceps were able to take
control so quickly was through the use
of spores like traditional zombies the
infected in The Last of Us game are able
to spread infection to new people
through bites and this is true for the
new series there's this really great
horrifying shot where fungal tendrils
are warming out of a woman's mouth to
infect someone else it is so gross it
was this moment that I'm like yes this
series gets it but in addition to
marching on the living the video game
version of the cordyceps were able to
infect new people through Airborne
spores produced in in the bodies of the
infected and this creates a huge threat
for all the survivors there are big
chunks of the game where our protagonist
Joel has to wear a gas mask to survive
he even keeps one on him at all times
just in case so yeah that's the way that
you get this sort of Rapid zombie spread
if the show had Airborne spores but it
doesn't one of the show's creators Craig
Mason previously worked on the series
Chernobyl for HBO which had a ton of
scenes with actors and hazmat suits and
gas masks Mason found that it was more
difficult to create drama when an
actor's face was covered by a bunch of
safety equipment hence Joel's gas mask
and the fungal spores having to go
nope no you're not Stephanie these
babies are no longer Airborne your dance
is non-canonical but if it's not spores
then what is it what's causing the
zombie fungus to spread surely there has
to be some sort of an explanation so I
dived into behind the scenes information
about the show hoping to find some
answers and though I didn't find an
explicit answer what I found instead was
a challenge in the official HBO Max Last
of Us post episode podcast they say this
by the way a lot of little details are
going to come back around we don't want
to give spoilers but I will say this
careful viewers of this episode will be
rewarded repeatedly because little bits
of breadcrumbs have been planted that
are going to pay off later in
interesting ways excuse me careful
viewers do you know who you're talking
to I've spent the last eight years porn
over every frame of movies and
television that I've watched
overthinking analyzing it you challenge
me to search and I will find it and you
know what loyal theorists I did I found
the answer to how exactly this fungal
parasite devastated the world so fast
and true to the Creator's word it was in
the small details that were hidden in
plain Insight all along how did the
world of The Last of Us end cookies or
more specifically the flower that was
used to bake those cookies allow me to
explain the first thing that tipped me
off about flour is this line right here
in the background one of the morning
scenes we can hear a radio broadcast
that specifically talks about problems
happening in Jakarta
Jakarta where is that Middle East it's
in Indonesia Joel learn some geography
anyway the call out of Jakarta
immediately struck me as odd why there
of all places seemed oddly specific well
in addition to beautiful beaches and
tropical architecture Jakarta also
happens to be home to the largest flower
Mill in the world this Behemoth run by
PT bogasari flower mills has 15 Milling
lines in fact it's able to produce more
than 4 million tons of flour each year
this fungal infection spreads through
flower products of course there's going
to be disturbances starting in Jakarta
hey guys this is a future matpat here so
this theory was written immediately
after I saw the first episode but uh
episode 2 actually gave us a little more
information about the Jakarta situation
in the show that is very often the risk
that we take when we do theories about
ongoing series anyway episode 2's cold
open takes place in Jakarta where a
professor at the University of Indonesia
is taking a look at one of the first
infected people we're told that this
infected person came from quote a flower
and grain Factory on the west side of
the city and then under her breath the
professor says a perfect substrate a
substrate in case you don't know is a
surface or material where an organism
like say a fungus can live grow and
obtain nourishment basically this
practically confirms our theory that
flower is the reason for the cordyceps
outbreak in the show so whoa we got it
right that said there's still a ton of
fun evidence here in the episode so I'm
just gonna hand it back off to pass map
hat now so you can keep watching and be
impressed with how we solved this week
early and then release the video a week
late what's more there are also tons of
flower mills All Over Texas in Dallas
Houston San Antonio and yes Austin where
the show's prologue takes place with so
many mills throughout Texas the state
would be a hot spot for an outbreak just
like we saw with Jakarta but fungi and
flower is that scientifically reasonable
flour is usually made from wheat or
other grains so how would a fungus get
in there well I hate to say it but you
know mold the gross stuff that grows on
food that's oiled or been left out for
too long that is a type of fungus so if
the wheat used make it has gone bad in
any way there's likely some fungus mixed
in there even freshly made flour out of
Mills has been shown to sometimes
contain fungus according to one study
there can be a ton of fungus inside of
commercial flower this study took 19
flower samples and 11 wheat samples from
11 different Mills across Kansas
Nebraska and Pacific Northwest in those
samples the fungal count and flower
ranged from 85 to 8 100 per gram and
between 90 and 1400 per gram in the
wheat in both cases spoilage of the
product was not the source of the fungus
stuff was just in there so if a fungus
can indeed be inside freshly milled
flour somehow why not cordyceps so with
me suddenly thinking that flower sus I
re-watched the episode again and
immediately you see a bunch of little
details starting to add up all
throughout the prologue we never once
see Joel Sarah or Tommy eat anything
flower based to the point where it's
almost a miracle in the morning though
Sarah's planned to make Joel pancakes
she can't because they don't have any
more pancake mix where's the pancake mix
I was gonna make you birthday pancakes
after school when Sarah visits their
neighbor Mrs Adler she turns down in an
offer to eat a cookie likely this is
because they're raisin cookies and
raisins are just awful lies masquerading
as chocolate chips but still this one
move may have meant that Sarah missed a
big old bite of zombie infection already
that'd be enough to raise some eyebrows
but the coincidences just keep going
that night when Joel gets home late they
realize that he's forgotten to pick up
the birthday cake that they were gonna
share where's the cake
come on man let's get this one tomorrow
and earlier in the day they saw Mr Adler
feeding his elderly mother biscuits in
fact when he offers some of the extras
to Sarah and Joel they declined Joel
even jokes that he loves biscuits but
I'm on Atkins Atkins is of course a fad
diet that recommends not eating any
bread or grain products obviously Joel
isn't actually on Atkins here given his
plan to have pancakes and birthday cake
but it's still an interesting thing for
the show to bring attention to isn't it
additionally in the parts of the first
episode set after the outbreak we never
actually see anyone eating any products
made from flour there's this big open
crowd shot where we can't make out
anyone's plates and there isn't any
bread scraps on Ellie's empty plate when
she's being kept prisoner basically the
only thing that we see anyone consuming
is Joel drinking some alcohol in short
this show goes very far out of its way
to never show us its main characters
explicitly eating flower-based product
hey this is future matpat here again
with some additional evidence that we
see happening in episode two we do
actually get someone eating bread during
the present day we see Ellie is eating a
sandwich which makes sense because she's
immune to the zombie outbreak and you
notice what Joel and Tess are eating
jerky no bread thought that was just
another little detail that was worth
pointing out the only immune person is
eating bread while everyone else
apparently isn't just cool little Easter
eggs that I found while licking the
wounds of this theory that came out too
late curse you extended editing pipeline
now I know what you're thinking wait
wouldn't the fungus just die off while
being baked and that's a really great
thing to call out yes according to the
United States Department of Agriculture
most yeast and mold fungi are super
sensitive to heat normally they can be
destroyed at temperatures of 140 to 160
degrees Fahrenheit or 60 to 71 degrees
Celsius and most ovens when their baking
cookies are set somewhere between 325
and 350 Fahrenheit or 163 to 177 C well
above those fungi kill in temperatures
even the most heat resistant fungi in
history found in 2011 by scientists in
India can only survive temperatures of
239 degrees Fahrenheit or 115c but all
of that being said fungi in the
production lines of baked goods and
bread products are still a massive
problem according to a study published
in food research international they
actually found more fungus and goods
after they'd been baked than anywhere
else in the cooking process basically
they say that the highest fungal counts
were seen in the final processing stages
of making the goods right after they'd
come out of the oven and were busy
Cooling and considering that the Last of
Us spent that whole opening scene
pointing out that the fungus in the
world evolved to survive at higher
temperatures it's entirely plausible
that the cordyceps made it out of the
oven and so now with all of that mind I
can't help but look back at the podcast
that got me started down this Rabbit
Hole to begin with you know what I
realized the answer has been staring me
in the face the entire time do you
remember exactly what was said by the
creators during that podcast careful
viewers of this episode will be rewarded
repeatedly because little bits of
breadcrumbs have been planted bread
crumbs huh like flour based breadcrumbs
they told us the answer right there
those cheeky sons of a gun and just to
put the cherry on top here the Piezo
resistance do you know what they were
talking about right before this in the
podcast that got him to start talking
about these little hints the intentional
trail of breadcrumbs we made a point of
making this sort of joke about how she
couldn't even eat Biscuits by the way a
lot of little details are going to come
back around we don't want to give
spoilers they were discussing the
elderly neighbor the first infected
person we see and how she was being fed
biscuits the evidence has mounted here
folks the Society of The Last of Us TV
show fell apart because the cordyceps
fungus evolved to be more heat resistant
to be able to take root in humans and
then its particles were were spread
worldwide through flour so Joel yes he
had plenty of reasons to say you know I
don't really like pancakes Your Atkins
diet might be saving more than just your
waistline but hey if you want to learn
more about the evil fungus science
behind this amazing story check out our
game theory talking about how Ellie
isn't actually immune to the cordyceps
infection or if you want more of a
strategy guide on how to survive a
post-apocalyptic Wasteland check out our
video explaining why musicians would
have the best chance of surviving a
quiet place as always don't forget to
take a big old bite out of that
subscribe button so you never miss a new
Theory there are a ton of great new
movies and shows coming out this year
that I can't wait to analyze alongside
you guys until then remember it's all
just a theory a film Theory and cuts
[Music]
thank you